former FBI director James Comey in an
interview here on special report let's
bring in our panel Catherine Herridge
Fox News chief intelligence
correspondent Molly Hemingway senior
editor at The Federalist Mar Elias a
national political correspondent of
National Public Radio and Joan Didion of
a former US Attorney Katherine first to
you you've covered this for a long time
what stuck out with you well the amazing
exchange to me is when you had director
Comey confirmed that he shared those
memos documenting conversations with the
president with three other people
so the Columbia professor that's what he
testified to also his what he described
as his personal attorney Patrick
Fitzgerald and then this other attorney
what's key here is that he told you
Brett that those memos were returned to
the FBI after they found classified
information he can call it whatever he
wants that is a classified spill of
information doesn't matter whether they
have clearances they didn't have the
ability to secure that information Joe I
was amazed I thought it was breathtaking
duplicity America's dirty cop continues
to amaze me with the destruction of the
institution that he used to lead and
what what Katherine has just said is
stunning it's not his decision he's
supposed to know what's classified he
has the authority to classify under the
law and yet he maintains that he did not
give away classified information he
leaked classified information to the New
York Times that's a crime mark I think
that the difficulty that Comey is having
is that he's now in a completely
different role and he can't be in two
roles at the same time the completely
impartial lawman who believes in serving
the presidency and the institutions and
now a partisan actor and that's I think
where there's a lot of conflict Amala I
thought his most interesting answer was
when you asked him if he would still be
at the FBI if he hadn't been fired and
he said he would be and it was because
he believed his job was to protect the
FBI I think it's a very telling
statement that suggests that there's
something other than justice that was
his high concern and when you were
asking him about why he didn't reveal
information to the president about who
funded the dossier he seemed to be
shockingly uninformed about who funded
the dossier he did not he in fact it I
want to play this now because I
I was prepared to go down a different
road and then he said he didn't know
when did you learn that the DNC and
Hillary Clinton campaign had funded
Christopher Steele's work yeah I still
don't know that for a fact I knew it was
funded first by Republicans up and down
I'm sorry that's not true that the
dossier that Christopher Steele worked
on was funded by Republican okay my
understanding was the activity was begun
that the steel was hired to look into
was first funded by Republicans then
picked up the important thing was picked
up by Democrats opposed to Donald Trump
the basics of journalism and any
investigation is understanding the
credibility of the source and the fact
that he didn't have his arms around what
the source was from the dossier was
really kind of confusing to me and then
just as a final point when you asked him
about that being the basis for the for
the FISA he says that it was just a
small piece and that's not what we're
learning that's a direct conflict with
what Republicans have said